you're dating her no but dating is your
war it's not exclusive what Gus come on
put some clothes on fine let's go I'm
driving where are your keys never mind I
got him
ooh should I slice this up for the road
what is that what is that it's the
doghouse no that's not what are you
talking about I gave you specifications
when when I gave you the job
in 1989 Shawn you know as well as I do
this is not what I asked for
keep working don't be too loud neighbors
are trying to sleep yeah
these governor Clements
you want to get out of here yes I do
hey Shawn smoothies you here an apple
of course thanks buzz you haven't food
delivered already going out what did I
tell you
now take a hit off this bad boy complete
the moment burned it what do you think
this is mr. Guster I apologize this will
never happen again
give me that boys out smoothie you know
these things stay hmm
but they are very delicious chief would
you like some that's not my smooth I
don't care whose smoothie it is I don't
even remember why I asked you to stay
now what is this you're looking at our
new business Mazel Tov
are you out of your mind you were to
offer space for this Gus don't be a
crazy hooligan
I rented a sign
now let's go say hello to our new
neighbors everyone who wants pineapple
be honest now you guys can slice it up
fight over later I'm sorry gentlemen
may I help you I'm Terrence I run the
line here Terrence
hello I'm Shawn Spencer this is my
partner Gus silly pants Jackson just
came by to say hello
we've opened up our own little 1-800
thingy down the hall not as big as you
guys more of a closet really your own
1-800 thingy yeah yeah it's called dial
a psychic maybe you recognize us I am
the lead psychic for the Santa Barbara
Police Department
McCallum murders Edmund robberies over
there you nothing wow really
what do you guys live in this room so
you can know stuff about me just just by
looking at me yeah pretty much well do
it do it go ahead show us looking for a
little demo one for one they don't like
pineapple I don't know guys I don't
think Big T wants us to take up any more
no go right ahead
you know half the lines are down phones
are being worked on right now we have
timed your little trick oh yeah what the
hell is a muscum it was a very common
name of the era History Channel ESP and
Gus channel 206 I'm begging you hey
Jules
[Music]
Wow
what let's see this huh know what I was
expecting
okay I know what I'm looking at but what
does it mean is it a ghost no buddy it's
not a ghost is there a woman living up
here
well that would certainly explain the
perfume Roberts been smelling and all
the red hair laying everywhere but no no
dice then what is it oh come on Gus look
in today there are more inches blazing
red phantom hair I think we'll always
get that before the blood showed up he's
probably gonna earn his day with
periscope so the kidnapper is the one
roasting this new movie online he also
wrote the guilty will pay the guilty
will pay Wow one of these comic book
freaks has clearly blurred the line
between reality and
comment the kidnappers still has one
more person so your Tricia says that
this is where her father comes every
morning for his coffee he was here when
he thought he saw the murder me so so
maybe we'll see something to let an
ex-cop to believe a murder had been
committed plus double chocolate mango
pineapple scones apparently made fresh
daily what I'm saying Gus the morning is
essentially a win-win thanks for giving
him this day I hope he remembers it
tomorrow he couldn't let go and move on
Shawn yeah what I'm sorry I left a lump
in my throat
speaking of lumps mm the ostrich the
tennis ball what you know what it's not
a big deal obviously but it always
bugged me a little why didn't you say
anything Trisha like what oh I don't
know I threw the tennis ball into the
highly restricted ostrich area and I let
you take the fall for it you're serious
it's not too late to make it right right
is right you really still have not grown
up have you Wow goodbye Shawn Gus
we just saw that woman at the courthouse
essentia penny a fourth grade teacher
who murdered Jackson the end don't you
watch the news
I can't watch turn away didn't work
Lloyd Lansing wears a toupee it's like
every newscast structured a lot it's
Danish God said about him just listen to
him Sandra panitch went with weatherman
Jackson Hale to his Channel 8 News
studio engaged in sexual relations with
him and then stabbed him in the heart
with a letter opener she fled the scene
and not without leaving behind a
mountain of physical evidence including
a trail of the victim's blood and her
fingerprints all over the murder weapon
this is why the state is going after
murder one what you know what comes from
getting a very strong feeling here I
think that woman is innocent I do watch
the news and I've been following this
case they have a mountain of evidence
against this lady look they call it a
school marm murderer okay first of all
there's a question mark at the end of
that they call her the school marm
murderer even the news people aren't
convinced and today at the courthouse in
the middle of a conversation
I saw her bend over and pick up a piece
of trash oh I see so because she picked
up somebody's Kit Kat wrapper me she
didn't kill anybody that makes sense
Gus she didn't have to do that the woman
is about to be on trial for her life she
takes time out for common courtesy that
is not the mindset of a cold-blooded
murderer No
Shawn I left my retreat to solve a crime
that's order takeouts exactly what we're
doing
hi there what time you turn those lights
on at 5:00 for the beginning of the
dinner crowd never any earlier for any
reason whatsoever it's on the timer it
was the point I think I know what the
tailor is one more question and this is
absolutely critical
do your samosas come with that red onion
chutney getting a very very strong
psychic vibration he's gonna lose big
now what my money's not why does put a
pineapple I'm sorry do I know you
my name is Ichabod Fleischman sticky
icky to my boys but that's neither here
nor there what's important is that this
baby is 82% Hawaiian and I've got all
afternoon are you a crazy person it's
funny I was about to ask you the same
thing only I was gonna add who likes to
make toast to the end of mine right so
you're another cop then not a cop not
even close
well then who are you
and Green Day there's about to eat such
down how did you do that
you